you know I'm gonna say this right now
okay
you literally oh version of me
all right yeah you don't look like Chris
Spencer so what funny funny and charming
what yeah yeah Bobby I know what I'm
working with
yeah you do right okay and I know what
I'm working with and we're the same no
not really
why we both look we both played the
video games uh-huh
like [ __ ] 12 year olds what I'm tall
[Laughter]
but that can change that always go back
you're always gonna be I know this is
how I met Eric Griffin how I know him
how long yeah okay so uh I met I met our
friend our good friend our man said hey
do you want to play the Middle East with
you Eric Griffin and Sebastian
Maniscalco and I said arm
you just farted yeah this is this is
what I'm saying
okay I'm not gonna it's a it's a gas I'm
not gonna clutch it in and keep it in my
body well you keep everything else in
that body so we play the middle Ian now
I don't know who he is yeah I mean I had
met him once before I did tell him about
how I acted it during this is so
embarrassing remember that one show the
first time yeah yeah you got a sense up
and I would say this right I don't know
how much was that almost killed was I'm
a TV at the time but I don't even
remember but you were the biggest dick
okay you tell them when I stop tell him
what a good so first of all he comes to
this show we had this great show out in
Newport Beach
we're paying comics in the city $1,000
to come do a show he comes and he's a
nightmare from the beginning to the end
like just the biggest diva I've ever
[ __ ] met what I do you were just
doing all kinds of [ __ ] you were like
you know it was like my car yeah yeah he
was just like complaining the whole time
but to show these people how dare you he
was like how dare I met a man booked me
in this shitty he was going on and on
about the show just the biggest worst
diva ever you know I had to call him at
like I met you need to come down here
because I'm about to kill Bobby Lee he
did not like me no it was the worst but
I didn't know who he was you know he
knew I was like yeah is he wearing the
glasses and the glasses of the nose that
they have I thought he was wearing one
of those things so what were you guys
conversations you guys even talk come on
man don't act like that I'm like [ __ ]
you man I was a [ __ ] crazy
yeah you crazy oh Christ are you sober
yeah yeah whoa God you just have diva
tennis is he still has diva oh god don't
even get me started what you know you
know I hate about you this day yeah it's
like you don't communicate properly no
like I have to text you a thousand
[ __ ] time for you to get back to me
you never answer your phone your [ __ ]
voicemail is always full you know how
does your do you know another phone do
you know how people get in contact how
they call you
you made the manager names you have to
call you tell Bobby that's ridiculous
Allen bill burr are having him are
having him on a podcast on Wednesday
didn't contact him they content
contacted me anything that any yeah any
time he has to be anywhere it's through
me I'm asked you a question
mmm-hmm have you ever heard of Ronan
look at me right now right now I'm
asking you a question
we're not Roman okay have you heard of
Roman you do Romans dry cleaning at best
okay you know what a Ronan is right a
masterless Samurai all right so what I
am is I'm wandering through these dirt
listening hard in Japan
I have a sword I'm scratching my back
and I'm walking through these dirt like
pathways and I'm just a wandering
samurai just longing for a home okay and
that's what I am
you have friends okay want to be in your
life and you are wrapped and you are
mine but it frustrates me when your ass
don't call back I hate that that's fine
because the things that you want I know
what you want yeah you do know you don't
get back on destiny there's a new deal
coming out I will defend him because I
see your messages pop up oh I'm playing
Fallout right you get this yeah because
I might hold on but you're gonna leave
me easily does it a thousand times until
I answer right so I know what you that's
all right so we're in the Middle East
Doron okay so then we I did that right
and then so I go to the Middle East and
I with Sebastian who's a dear friend and
I literally just we I saw Eric Griffin
perform very at the for the very first
time on stage and I literally watched
him and I said this is years ago like a
decade ago right that long ago I was
like five or six years ago no it's
farther long it's not like I started in
all right so five six years ago and I
saw him for the first time and I said
this guy is really legitimately funny
well and he doesn't look like something
just shut the [ __ ] up
that's something out of the story though
I know we're gonna get to that but you
shut the [ __ ] up all right and I
literally cuz he doesn't look like that
he is gonna be that funny when you see
him you know man now because now I can
put that ugly face into your comedy and
I'm like okay now I get how the
packaging works right but at the time
I'm like that packaging is so awful it's
like [ __ ]
it's like a it's like a [ __ ] elephant
[ __ ] and then they put glasses on it and
they put it out here I mean so it's like
but now I'm like this is all because no
matter how I blasted here so I looked at
Suresh and I said this guy's [ __ ] and
then we legitimately became friends we
went to Bahrain Abu Dhabi we went to
Beirut well there's more to the story
okay
Bobby had bombs so bad
he thought it was the crowd you know
yeah while these people just don't get
comedy yeah yeah and there I was awful
it isn't what you really said to me he
does a story go to me said when I saw
you on stage and what you did a single
tear came down my face yeah yeah we had
a good time okay Xbox and we started
playing Fifa and that was what we did
yeah
[Music]